In this video, we'll discuss
how we can create visualizations
that are used in
predictive policing models.
In almost every
application, before we even
consider a predictive
model, we should
try to understand
the historical data.
Many cities in the United
States and around the world,
provide logs of reported crimes,
usually the time, location,
and nature of the event.
In this lecture, we'll use
data from the city of Chicago,
in the United States,
about motor vehicle thefts.
Given this data
on crimes, suppose
we wanted to communicate
crime patterns
over the course of
an average week.
We could display daily crime
averages using a line graph,
like the one shown here, but
this doesn't seem too useful.
We can see that crime tends to
be higher on Saturday, but when
on Saturday, and where?
We could replace our x-axis
with the hour of the day
and have a different line
for every day of the week
to understand when crime
occurs in more detail.
But this would be a jumbled mess
with seven lines, and probably
very hard to read.
We could instead use no
visualization at all,
and instead present
information in a table,
like the one shown here.
For each hour and day,
we have the total number
of crimes that occurred.
This is a valid
representation of the data,
but large tables of numbers can
be hard to read and understand.
So how can we make the table
more interesting and usable?
A great way to
visualize information
in a two-dimensional
table is with a heat map.
Heat maps visualize data
using three attributes.
Two of the attributes are on
the x and y-axes, typically
displayed horizontally
and vertically.
The third attribute is
represented by shades of color.
In this example, lower
values in the third attribute
correspond to colors
closer to blue,
and higher values in
the third attribute
correspond to colors
closer to red.
For example, the x-axis
could be hours of the day,
the y-axis could be
days of the week,
and the colors could correspond
to the amount of crime.
In a heat map, we can pick
different color schemes
based on the type of data to
convey different messages.
In crime, a yellow
to red color scheme
might be appropriate
because it can highlight
some of the more
dangerous areas in red.
Your eye is naturally drawn
to the red areas of the plot.
In other applications,
both high and low values
are meaningful, so having
a more varied color scheme
might be useful.
And in other applications,
you might only
want to see cells
with high values,
so you could use a gray scale to
make the cells with low values
white.
The x and y-axes in a heat map
don't need to be continuous.
In our example, we have a
categorical or factor variable
-- the day of the week.
And we can even
combine a heat map
with a geographical
map, which we'll
discuss later in this lecture.
This type of heat map
is frequently used
in predictive policing to show
crime hot spots in a city.
In this lecture, we'll use
Chicago motor vehicle theft
data to explore patterns
of crime, both over days
of the week, and over
hours of the day.
We're interested in analyzing
the total number of car thefts
that occur in any
particular hour
of a day of the week
over our whole data set.
In the next video,
we'll switch to R,
and start by
creating a basic line
plot counting the total
crime by the day of the week.